so you're saying what were you just
saying though about Beyonce so you know
a lot of these talent shows they use
these top 40 songs to audition and we're
right
so I beginning at beginning as an older
person being able to appreciate simple
strong structures but it's based on the
singing you know because there's a lot
of songs that like Whitney Houston I
didn't even know a single Whitney
Houston song until I started watching
technology I thought she was a crack
addict seen a reality show and Bobby
Brown laughter I just the photos online
of her like dried lips and like yummy
twisted hello she's a streetwalking
crack addict mmm I didn't know that she
was this talented person I'm everyone
but then when you watch like talent
shows you know someone will sing a
Whitney song and and the audience or the
judges will be like this is gonna be
difficult because it's Whitney you know
I mean this is a very difficult song you
know so you know I appreciate songs
where it's difficult to sing and that's
why I'm beginning not necessarily
Beyonce but there are certain people
like I didn't know who Kelly Clarkson
was early Shakey's or Alicia Keys or any
of these people but because I want right
I remember when you made your first
divas playlist yeah I did and you were
like look sweetie it's Beyonce and Mary
J bleed now mary j blige she's cool like
I like her I mean I just I I just find
Beyonce's song is kind of boring yeah
yeah yeah and I agree with you I think
you know but I've always been into um
people that play instruments and write
songs and he does no no engine in
general right me too yeah I I you know
when you're raised with I was raised
with the stones and the Beatles and you
know and then like the of an underground
and Roxy Music all these you know all
these you always like new music - I love
you yeah yeah I like new stuff and have
you made the switch to hip-hop it's
because you kind of have to because
that's all that people care about
anymore I know it's been hard for me you
don't like the Wills with us the little
C I'm gonna write write that down no
like Lil P
I was gonna Google I'm trying to name
this little bow yeah yeah little bow Wow
no no here anyone listening right now I
and and I really want to be an open
person and I want to absorb new things
and if you're like really into hip-hop
and really know what the cool things are
that I should listen to that's a you
know that's kind of innovative and
forward give me a list email tiger belly
give me a list of of hip hop hip hop
yeah yeah that I can dive into because
you know I have all the Spotify and all
that stuff and I I'd be happy to
you know dive into it but you don't you
don't really listen to much hip-hop well
I mean in the early in the late 80s I
listen to like what my brother listened
to like dress not Rasik fly but um tribe
I love drastic fight also but Tribe
Called Quest you know um those kinda
Fugees I like them I like you know those
earlier ones and then as it got older I
got aggressive like I would go into
Chris Delia's car and hear that some
sort of like a really aggressor a
brandishing guns going off and people
dying and I just didn't like what about
me goes I love the three amigos is that
a ban do you like me goes I do i I can't
do migos but I am in love with a 22 year
old I love post Malone so much see if
Bobby would get into that have you know
post him along I know pre moment one
came along as my favorite I think Bobby
would like post Malone I don't think
he'd like me goes at all me goes is like
funny that's Viet it's funny it's funny
can we play it on here yeah you play
stir fry for him wait with the onion
line in it yeah but is it surprising a
is an Asian oriented no Bob okay it's a
believe it's about cocaine oh you guys
say music I'm here
we never possibly found you the first
time yeah yeah I'll get turn it off I'm
gonna get it yeah yeah what stir-fry
please wait did you really like it I
like the crew little bit and I like the
group but here's another thing is is
that um but here's the thing about
hip-hop very different than like Tribe
Called Quest political I mean these
these these guys are all it's all about
like drug and knowledge like right but
the music right is sometimes very
melodic and interesting it's just my
thing it just totally for me is that
when they start wrapping it all sounds
the same to me in terms of like the
cadence you know there's no melody
sometimes the in the chorus will sing a
melody but hip about the Devon you know
it's all the same you know yeah yeah for
me it's little I'm not at they're just
my way of thinking like what about Drake
don't even know who yes well no I just
do a podcast where we talk about the top
songs that's how I know like what's in
the top Billboard top 5 but did you know
that three of the top five songs are
Drake no is that big yes yeah he can
blur the lines with different audiences
really so like hipsters like Drake
everyone like my people loved her why
people love drag Canadian yeah what he's
Canadian yeah he was he was on I
remember and I adapt the Degrassi that I
watch I don't watch a new generation but
I don't think anyone's ever had three
out of the five songs be their band
that's incredible yeah but you know he's
Canadian I'm probably gonna like them
you think why is that because um this is
gonna sound and I want to I'm good just
to try to tiptoe away from right but
just baby just just hear me out okay
it's here's what the thing is is that
you know a lot of times when I listen to
hip-hop I don't like the violence right
or like Street you know life when people
talk because it to me
from the suburbs I don't relate I like
these guys
Drake is not industries that's what
that's what I'm saying that's one thing
Drake if he's from Canada right he's you
know he'd the dog maple trees hockey
sticks he was an actor before he was a
rapper nobody my point is cuz I've been
to Canada right yeah a lot of beautiful
snow very good writing code nature right
so he is not from the streets of TV what
Toronto where's he from
cosmopolitan it's like everyone's so
nice the food's great great culture
there's no violence
[Music]